c'est l'autre événement aéronautique de
l'année après le lancement de l'a380
dassault vient de dévoiler son nouvel
avion d'affaires le falcon 7x si vous
voulez vous l'offrir il faut compter
tout de même 29 millions d'euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent mais les carnets de
commandes sont déjà pleins le secteur
des avions privés est en plein boom
patrice pollet yann moines
25 mètres de long autant de large ce
nouvel avion l'un des plus imposants
dans la catégorie des avions d'affaires
haut de gamme pour 29 millions d'euros
selon les désirs du client
l'intérieur peut ressembler à ça luxe
mais aussi tout ce qu'il faut pour
travailler pour le piloter un cockpit
ultra moderne il n'a rien à envier
l'airbus a380 c'est du même niveau
l'avion se pilote avec des mini manches
et la présentation des informations est
poussé au maximum nous on a poussé très
loin l'intégration de manière à ce que
les choses soient extrêmement convivial
facile à comprendre que le ce qu'on
appelle la conscience de la situation
soit excellente contrairement à l'idée
reçue ce ne sont pas les vedettes du
show biz qui achètent en priorité ses
avions 90 % des acquéreurs sont des
hommes d'affaires ou des sociétés à bord
on travaille après les états unis
l'objectif visé par dassault aviation
c'est l'europe qui s'agrandit tous les
jours eva sont du niveau économique
qu'entraîne l'élargissement de l'europe
va faire que les besoins vont augmenter
dans un certain nombre de pays nouveau
en europe et donc tous ces gens vont
avoir besoin de se dépasser eux aussi
sur la totalité de la planète
impressionnant 23500 avions d'affaires
sont en service dans le monde contre
seulement 21 mille avions de ligne un
avion d'affaires décolle toutes les 45
secondes et 10 fois plus d'aéroport
peuvent les recevoir en 40 ans dassault
aviation a vendu 1800 falcone elles
placent aujourd'hui la france parmi les
premiers vendeurs de la planète c'est
autant d'argent qui contribuent à la
balance de notre commerce extérieur
[Musique]